well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored Harry and Megan
the currently the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex famously gushed about their love
of chickens in one of the more
saccharine moments of the Oprah Winfrey
SOB Fest well the chickens are now
coming home to roost for these two the
royal family kept the stoic silence as
The Poisoned darts rained down from
their Californian pedestal but King
Charles is quietly and devastatingly
taking charge now we now know that he
booted the couple out of their palatial
Frogmore Cottage just 24 hours after
Harry's books spare or spare me as I
call it was published we also now know
that Harry and Megan's popularity is
crated on both sides of the Atlantic
with polls showing even prince Andrew is
now more popular than they are in
America as well as now being offered the
keys to their house
and we also know that in America well
they've strained every sinew to become
much less celebrities that are actually
viewed like this
so let me start with you Sam you've
lived a life with the royal family
you've had everything handed to you but
you say your life has been hard and now
you've written all about it in your new
book where
yes that's right fans you see my wife
and I are totally like you should write
a book because your family like stupid
and then so are like journalists
there's not a clear divide in the royal
family the workers and the shirkers the
heavy lifters and the grifters The
Prince and Princess of Wales literally
Welsh guards yesterday it's in Davis Day
Parade Camilla the queen consort
recovering from a reason about a covid
was promoting children's literature King
Charles is preparing to make State
visits to Germany and France in his
first world tour as Monarch like a
Markle meanwhile made a state visit to a
coffee shop which sells superfood lattes
inspired by holistic ingredients from
around the world and Prince Harry had
another outing on U.S late night
television The Leftovers of a previous
interview taped on his self pity tour
Harry
what is the best sandwich
I would say a cheese and ham toasty with
Dijon mustard on top
toasty means grilled okay there you go
unbelievable like guys sixth in line to
the throne on Saturday he's out of the
game vlogging tickets to a digital
seminar family trauma his trauma from
his 13 million dollar Californian
mansion
uh you have to pay 33 by the way to tune
in online
to see him banging on about his trauma
again and what a victim he is and how
it's also beastly and unfair that he's
making hundreds of millions fleecing his
Royal titles without doing any world
Duty for it but that's his level Now
isn't it for Harry a gossiping gutter
snipe selling out his family to the
highest bidders a wannabe reality star
but that star is fading fast Harry and
Megan think they can carry on having
their Royal cake and eating him
using those Royal titles I can say while
abusing the institution that afforded
them those titles and as usual I'm
afraid they're wrong and King Charles is
right to draw the curtain on this
ludicrous soap opera on May the sect the
King has his coronation it will be one
of the most important moments in modern
British history and the very last thing
we need or want are the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex current titles rocking up with
their camera Crews to distract attention
and get more material for their next Act
of money grabbing betrayal next week 2
000 invitations will be sent out in live
view it's time for Charles to be firm
and make sure they're not on that list
well joining me now is the sun wrong
auditor Matt Wilkinson political
journalist Ava Santina plus an authoring
columnist Maureen caliber welcome to all
of you let me start with you Matt great
scoop I mean this was a proper
eye-popping scoop particularly now that
we know that the order to evict Harry
and Megan from Frogmore Cottage came
from King Charles within 24 hours of the
launch of spare back on January the 10th
yeah no it's astonishing I mean
Charles I see he's acted very quickly
very decisively and particularly it was
so close to a spec so close to after
spare and he's seen the the family's
traumas the family splits everything
that's happened with Megan and Harry and
Andrew that kind of poisoned the last
three or four years of of the Queen's
Reign sadly and you could say that
Charles has finally by kicking them out
of Frogmore he's kind of finally
delivered mexit no I don't suppose
you'll lose my sleep over Meghan Markle
um disappearing at a far more College he
probably will lose some sleep over this
action in relation to his son because
he's his son it's very sad that he's got
to this day doesn't it really I mean
we're always told and he has shown as
well that we're always told that he
dearly loves his son and the door is
always open to his son when Harry came
over recently they came out they came
over Megan and they came over and they
met her at Clarence House and I think
it's an intense disappointment and
sadness for Charles that it has actually
got to this stage yes it's bringing more
from across the pond over in East
Hampton Maureen thank you for joining us
and I was staggered last week to see a
poll that said that Megan and Harry
since the release of this book and the
Netflix documentary are now less popular
in the US than prince Andrew I mean that
was jaw-dropping
oh here's it's remarkable really uh
there's no love lost here for prince
Andrew believe me
um I think the the real sort of final
Wallop to their reputation here one that
leaves no doubt where the bulk of the
American public stands on these two was
the South Park episode so for the South
Park episode to Air and it went viral
and people could not stop talking about
it to then be followed up with this
incredibly it's a sad decision but it
feels very necessary for King Charles to
remove them to send a clear message that
what you are doing and what you are
continuing to do as you pointed out with
this Saturday's upcoming wing-a-thon
online for 33.99 with pre-vetted
questions no live comments I do believe
that's King Charles saying there are
more things we can take away from you if
you do not stop harming this family
right I completely agree well look Ava
you're in the uh well the unenviable
position of trying to defend these two
because I think pretty much everyone
else we tried to get to do it didn't
want to know I mean they've lost even
their keenness supporters are you still
standing in team Sussex no I have never
been team Sussex I've always been team
Auntie monarchy and anti-royal I don't
think that any of them actually have a
place at the top of the hierarchy in the
UK anymore I think it's outrageous that
they even had entitlements still to this
Cottage I mean when they renovated it
they charged three million pounds to the
taxpayer which I know they eventually
paid back but the idea that three
million pounds was taken away
potentially from paying nurses from
paying teachers and re-wallpapering that
Cottage well the truth about the royal
family is though that the costs of
maintaining the royal family are offset
by the money they bring in oh they are
oh come on they're offset by the money
that comes in particularly listen people
comments
I have been yeah that was the hundredth
time that Arsenal have beat Everton yeah
that last night I
just want to make sure you're okay thank
you thank you so delicate tonight um but
yeah the point about the monarchy though
is you're wrong about that because you
may not like the idea of it that's fine
but they don't actually cost the country
any money they're a net positive they
cost the country a fortune and Prince
Charles has a lot of us Prince Charles
has a lot of his own money actually
enough to sustain himself he does not
need to be taking money off the
taxpayers to live his life you can keep
telling me they cost a lot of money they
don't okay
it would come without them they would
come to see the castles this also the
incredible good work that they do not
for their own benefit but for the
benefit of the country they don't have
to go out and work for all the do all
this wonderful work for Charities they
don't have to go out and race profile
for Charities
without getting upset I would happily
read a book today like Camilla did and
then get to live in a palace off the
back of that it's a lot harder job than
that I could have been to prisons and
read books I'll do that also every Tony
spitting cough of your private life was
just battered across the papers would
you be comfortable fine fine
[Laughter]
given I failed to even rally a tiny
Slither of support from me for the
Sussex news that's obviously the white
crowd of all abandoned them